all right before we get started I want
to thank the sponsor of this video this
video is brought to you by Mack Weldon
there'll be the shirt I'm wearing in
case you couldn't tell by that dramatic
intro but they really are the
one-stop-shop for men's basics of all
kinds socks shirts underwear hoodies so
a new adjustable storm chaser rain
jacket which I'm from Washington we know
a thing or two about rain and we never
use umbrellas jackets though yeah and
Mac Weldon really does value its loyal
customers that's why they created the
Weldon blue loyalty program here's how
it works
create an account that's totally free
then place an order for any amount you
never pay shipping again that's level
one then once you purchased $200 worth
of product from Mac well then that gets
you to level two not only will you
continue to get free shipping level two
also grants you access to new products
before they're released to anyone else
as well as free gifts added to future
orders I wanted something I could use in
video so I got me some shirts along the
spectrum of dark blue light blue and
blues and purples that's my pocket right
there so click the link below to go to
Mac Weldon comm slash John's enter promo
code John's get yourself 20 percent off
your order which would also have free
shipping so there you go saving more
money I've got your back and thank you
very much to Mack Weldon for sponsoring
this video it really helps me out a lot
I do appreciate it all right let's see
if Staten Island has a king
[Music]
the king of Staten is land welcome to
Staten Island there's so many interests
I could do so many dad jokes anyhow King
is that now so the king of Staten Island
is the newest Judd Apatow film stars
Pete Davidson Pete Davidson's character
in this movie his father was a
firefighter who was killed putting out a
fire and Pete Davidson's father in real
life was a firefighter who was a first
responder who was killed as a result of
the 9/11 attacks so you get this is
probably a very personal project for
Pete Davidson and it being a Judd Apatow
film it's very Judd Apatow for better or
worse well first of all what I like
about the movies I thought Pete Davidson
was really good there's just something
like connected with with his character
also I mean I like Pete Davidson I just
I really I dig dark humor and I don't
get why people are like all right it's
time for dark humor to be no more we
need dark humor because if you're a
human being you're [ __ ] up and Pete
Davidson has that in this movie he plays
the role really well which I mean some
people are probably gonna be like yeah
but he kind of plays Pete Davidson I
mean I could be in a movie titled the
YouTube movie review guy about a guy who
talks movie reviews online doesn't mean
oh what have really good at it but I
thought Pete Davidson did a really good
job also I like the fact that this movie
conveys what comics comedians otherwise
funny people who don't go onstage it
just kind of shows who they are on the
inside generally people are funny as a
defense mechanism it's a shield not a
sword it's they have pain it's how
they've dealt with their pain and in
this movie it's very apparent that Pete
Davidson's characters that's how he
deals with pain he's hiding a life
there's a lot of this dude shoulders
just emotionally speaking and you feel
that and that's what this movie is it's
the Odyssey of this person's life for
however long the movie takes players
would in a matter of weeks but it's the
growth that this character needs to find
you would swear if you watch the trailer
it's about this guy who interns at a
fire department that's not until the
last half-hour of the movie really it's
about this person not knowing where
they're going making all the bad
decisions so he's not a bad person he's
just trying to figure his [ __ ] out I
thought the supporting cast was good to
like build burrows one of my favorite
comics he plays a pretty large role in
the movie he's great he brings that Bill
burr wit but also he's a little toned
back he's less cynical than bill burr
comes across us and in true Judd Apatow
fashion that the dialogue among the
friends it was just connectible
relatable friend dialog it was funny it
was woody there were more than a few
times in this movie I laughed pretty
hard you got the chuckles but you also
have the hard laughs and also yes the
movie has heart and get serious when it
needs to also in true Judd Apatow
fashion the movies longer than it needs
to be and you feel it I know I've said
that about a few movies lately but know
this anytime I say that about a movie I
think of Judd Apatow
he's like the gold standard of that
every one of his movies is longer than
it probably needs to me this is a two
hour and 17 minutes dude figuring his
[ __ ] out this movie is going to connect
with you or not based on how you connect
with the character and what he's dealing
with in the movie and I personally did I
suppose I get what it's like to be in
your mid-twenties not knowing what the
[ __ ] you're gonna do in life I heard I
heard someone I forgot the youtubers
said something like youtubers are
homeless people like if YouTube didn't
happen they'd be homeless I think
they're people who got lucky I concede
to that absolutely if YouTube didn't
happen I'd still be at a movie theater
starting movies that's what I'd be doing
I'd be a projection it turns out it kind
of tripped and fell into something that
works and I'd like to think I work hard
at it the point is I know what it's like
to be in this character she's just
absolutely you didn't know that did you
behind this put together exterior is the
soul of that man short asleep you'll
ever have to take Everett I that I my
connection with the movie and the
character started out pretty early in
the movie he says something about being
on antidepressants which I gotta say
2020 was a great year for me to start
lexapro I didn't know what 2020 was
gonna bring us I didn't know it was
going to be 2-1 she had no idea but I
can only imagine my state of mind
without it I'd be a [ __ ] wreck funny
thing is for the longest time I was
really resistant to the idea I was like
I don't wanna get Medicaid again I my
face with that [ __ ] alright so excuse me
while I go and worry about everything
bad that can possibly happen and
mentally deal with it as though it is
most definitely going to happen so yeah
here's the good decision making yeah
your dicks gonna only work 75% but yeah
doesn't it's fine pick up pills for that
to me in the movie was kind of a
dialogue and passing but uh-huh it's
cool I got where he's coming from
so for me in the end I did I connected
with the movie drags its feet a little
bit shirts a little long for nothing
else you're just kind of watching a guy
go through his month it doesn't really
tell how much time passes it's a very
relatable movie for a lot of people
because I think there's more people out
there who don't have their [ __ ] figured
out or didn't at that age then do or did
I thought the king of Staten Island was
a good time to alcohol required for Tony
you could find it on a like I rented it
on Amazon Prime it's 20 bucks to rent
that's how much things cost to buy but
if you get like a crew of four people
together if you get the whole family or
group of friends and you just pay 20
bucks and although you can watch it I
guess you're saving money more so than
if you washed it in the movie theaters
but it was just you yeah you're getting
robbed this is the elevator at least
have one friend over so it's kind of
like the cost of a movie ticket so the
king of Staten Island have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
you